hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals which is a preparatory work
Immanuel Kant is going to give us three
different formulations of the
categorical imperative or at least
that's what he says that he's doing the
first two formulations are pretty
straightforward he provides us with a
lot of interesting examples good bit of
discussion of those there's not a lot of
controversy about precisely what the
formulations are although they can be
translated in slightly different ways
depending on the text that you're using
when it comes to the third formulation
it's a little bit looser as to you know
consensus about exactly what Kant
is calling the third formulation a
little bit later on in the text when he
talks about the three different modes of
presenting the principle what he calls
the principle of morality he does give
us a formulation in terms of the kingdom
of ends he says that you know all
Maxim's ought to by their own
legislation harmonize with a possible
kingdom of ends as with a kingdom of
nature and and we'll come back to that
notion of the kingdom of ends and a bit
but earlier on in the text he talks in
terms of the third practical principle
that is the the principle for
practically reasoning for for you know
practical reason determining what it is
that our duty is and by you know
contrast to that what our duty is you
know is not what we shouldn't be doing
or where you know things are sort of in
the middle and he's contrasting this
with the other two and he talks here
about the idea of the will of every
rational being as a universally
legislative will and you might say well
what does that actually mean first off
we want to reiterate as with all of the
things that we're talking about here in
the groundwork then this is not meant to
be something that's an
here achill generalization this is meant
to be something that we we actually
arrive at through practical reasoning
not by having experience of this sort of
saying this is something that we can
conceive of
even though perhaps it has never existed
so every rational being the will of that
rational being for whoever it happens to
be would be a universally legislative
will what does this mean
this is going to have to do with the
motives or in some if you want to think
about it this way the lack of what we
normally think of is known is for the
the actual willing that's going to take
place like constants going to tell us a
will of this sort cannot depend upon any
interest and if we think about as he
points out why it is that we regard
certain things to be our duty and why we
make ourselves or will for ourselves to
actually do those those things and you
know you might think about let's take an
example it's often easier if we do that
think about the duty you make a promise
to somebody you should follow through on
that promise you should do what it is
that you said that you are going to do
now why should you do it well you could
come up with all sorts of motives by
which you're making that that will those
could be turned into what Kant calls
Maxim's right so think about you know
you make a promise of somebody why
should you follow through on your
promise because otherwise you might hurt
their feelings and you really don't like
to hurt people's feelings because that
makes you feel bad well that would be an
interest or you shouldn't you know break
the promise because then people won't
trust you or because you're going to
lose some money or because if you do
that perhaps it'll lower your status in
social media or we could go on and on
and on with all sorts of interesting
possibilities but any of those things
that fall into the domain of interest
even if there are large scale interest
like well I should follow through on my
promise because my entire country is
depending upon me and I don't want to
let them down
unless you can general not generalize it
universalize it right to turn into a
universally legislative will taking out
any any interest it's not going to be
what we're looking for here
cut calls this the principle of autonomy
that is nothing else is making you
decide other than the sheer fact that it
is indeed your duty you recognize it if
so you recognize that it's rational to
fulfill duty you know departing from or
setting aside any interest that you
might have of course this doesn't mean
that any existing you know empirical
being won't have a whole bunch of
interest going on but can't does think
that it's possible for us to in some
cases you know put those aside and and
will in a universally legislative way
that would be for everybody we would say
not only is this the right thing for me
to do in these circumstances this is the
right thing for anybody placed in these
circumstances to do regardless of what
their background is regardless of you
know who they're connected to regardless
of whatever interests or motives or
inclinations desires all these other
things that can't contrast against pure
Duty now I mentioned that we would come
to talk about a kingdom of ends because
in fact frame this in terms of the
kingdom events and so many people in
talking about the third formulation of
the categorical imperative are going to
focus primarily on that he talks about
this immediately after talking about the
principle of autonomy and he says you
know in a kingdom what do we have we
have a union of different rational
beings and that union is carried out by
a system of common laws now this may not
actually exist this is a possible
kingdom of end this is a way of
understanding things by which we are
treating everybody
along the lines of the second
categorical imperative as ends when a
person is treating him or herself as an
end that means that they actually decide
for themselves in an autonomous fashion
they do not subordinate their will to
other partial considerations now if we
also think about how we treat other
people as ends and how they treat us as
ends rather than as mere means for
whatever it happens to be their
satisfaction their honor their you know
life plan something along those lines we
have eventually this notion of a kingdom
of ends a kingdom in which everybody is
you might say living according to the
same system of rules that every single
one of them can get behind because as he
says in a kingdom of ends like this the
rational being gives and is also subject
to these universal laws so every single
member of the kingdom of ends both gives
these laws because they're a rational
being and they see that these laws
really make sense
they they exclude things that we have to
exclude that are say logically
incoherent and they also are subject to
those ones they also follow them so you
know it could be that in an empirical
fashion there actually is a government
who you know enacts laws and you follow
the laws that they have not because it's
the government you need to follow them
so you're not scared and you know
anything like that but because you
recognize in what they're doing as
something like a prefiguration or a
symbol or whatever you want to call it
of this possibility of an entire kingdom
of ends in which everybody is in fact
treated as possessing human dignity or
the highest degree of value as opposed
to being treated as mere and so he will
you know go on and a little bit later
say that this is
here we go
we should act that the will could at the
same time regard itself is giving its
Maxim's universal laws if now the
maximum of rational beings are not by
their own nature coincident with this
then the the necessity of acting on is
practical necessity and the cetacean or
duty this is what we have to do in real
circumstances and by doing so we are
getting a little bit closer we are
perhaps even taking a concrete step
towards something like the kingdom of M
which may in fact never be empirically
realized but this does provide us
eventually he says with this maxim that
all Maxim's a lot by their own
legislation to harmonize with a possible
kingdom of ends whatever I choose for
myself I'm not only choosing sort of
universally the way the first
formulation said I'm not only you know
trying to do things in such a way that I
don't treat other people as mere means
but I'm doing this on a global scale you
might say this so if we understand it
this way this categorical imperative
that you know the third formulation is
really bringing the other two together
in a way that makes them you might say
even more Universal than what we've been
talking about in relation to the other
two